i think that you samantha b are uh
grossly
overrated i don't want to say grossly
overrated i think you're immensely
untalented
unfunny to a point that i very rarely
use the word offensive
but you are offensively unfunny and what
bothers me even more
is that a no talent mediocre nothing
wants to remove voices simply because
they disagree with her and they happen
to be more successful than her
question of the day now we've talked
about big tech's clear
censorship and throttling of of the
right uh for a while and
we'll discuss that in relation to
samantha b and prager you the most
recent controversy but
to conservatives out there i i'm curious
what would be required
i mean if anything for you to call for
the banning or shadow banning of a
left-wing
channel or a host like samantha b short
for
b i've i've never seen a mass movement
like this from the right like i've seen
boycotts but i've never seen anyone on
the right calling for channels or hosts
to be removed so
it's just a thought exercise i'm curious
to hear your thoughts um she's a little
desperate
all right so some context here samantha
b's her latest crusade
is about proving that conservatives are
not being centered on social media uh
according to samantha b big tech is
actually bowing to the right's demands
and the case
um she was talking specifically about
prager you let's
let's before we get to prageru let's
just take this and i'm so sorry that you
have to watch these clips
but and i know this is the only place
anyone's seeing samantha bee
let's go to cliff i'm very tired last
week
a major pro-trump pack ran facebook ads
that falsely claimed joe biden
criminally abused his power
a lie that misinforms voters about
trump's impeachment case
the only thing joe biden has criminally
abused is this ice cream cone
oh boy i don't think i have the strength
i don't think i can do this today yeah
she's
so it hurts well you did difficult this
year did say that trump was guilty for
saying
i had gotten a commitment from
poroshenko and from yetunic and they
would take action against the state
prosecutor they didn't so they said they
had
they were walking out to a press
conference i said nah i'm not going to
i'm not going to give you the billion
dollars i said i'm telling you you're
not getting the billion dollars
you're not getting the billion i'm going
to be leaving here in i think it was
about six hours and i looked at him and
said i'm leaving in six hours if the
prosecutor's not fired
you're not getting the money well son of
a [ __ ] he got fired oh wait i think you
know
spoiler that was joe biden oh i said i'm
telling you you're not getting the
billion dollars
i said you're not getting the billion
i'm gonna be leaving here i think it was
about six hours i look i said i'm
leaving in six hours
if the prosecutor's not fired you're not
getting the money
oh son of a [ __ ] got fired
am i the only one who doesn't believe
that that man ever quit drinking for
three years the leftist media
falsely claimed that donald trump
colluded with russia that he abused his
powers that he obstructed investigations
he was acquitted of all of these charges
should
should every member of the dnc be banned
from facebook i do believe so yes
you do not i do not believe so by the
way this is important because she's been
pushing these lies for a long time
from painting brett kavanaugh as a race
uh rapist right also a racist i'm sure
spreading the donald trump the the p
tape hoax
this time last year republicans
fast-tracked this poison ivy leaguer to
the supreme court
despite incredible accusations of sexual
assault
just one of those classic moments where
the first black president gives a
farewell speech while the next president
watches two chicks piss on a bed
oh hatch i don't even know what's with
that jacket too
it looks like she's about to convince a
small iowa town that she's a band
director
yes i don't know if anybody's seen music
yeah it looks like anybody it looks like
waldo would swipe right from here
[Laughter]
i'm sorry it's in my head love to claim
they're actually the victims of bias
from social media companies
people are very concerned that
conservative voices are going to be
suppressed
on social media these social media
outlets
censor public figures who are
conservatives cruz isn't the only
conservative who thinks big tech is
hiding his post because he's right wing
they even have a special name for it
they shadow band jim jordan and mark
meadows and ronna mcdaniel
every day i receive thousands of
messages i'm being shadow banned to be
clear
there's no evidence that shadow banning
conservatives is a thing
even though the president has been
collecting his own data
i have people come up to me sir we want
to follow you they don't let us on
she's right in a manner of speaking and
that conservatives aren't being shadow
banned anymore they're being
outright banned that's true this can
look absurd if your audience is not
aware of what's been happening
with social media but anyone who's been
following it knows that this is
apple they've banned apps just for being
pro-life right
same thing with pinterest instagram
facebook youtube they've all banned
sites like infowars along with other
conservatives
this is important to know we'll get to
our situation in the vox apocalypse
again
sorry guys i really didn't mean for it
to happen so let's move on to
my favorite topic to um be berated on
from comedians the banning of free
speech
or any views with which they disagree
here she goes on prague are you
prageru is actually a massively
successful part of a
growing hub of the online right-wing
media machine
they've been funded by mega donors and
their videos are specifically aimed at
middle school and high school children
even worse those videos get billions of
views
gregory is actually dangerous they are
reaching
a new younger audience with [ __ ]
conservative propaganda
trick kids into thinking their videos
are educational even though prageru
is as much of a real college as monsters
university
prageru which itself is short for prager
university
as in their own website saying prager
university is not an accredited academic
institution
but it is a place where you are free to
learn so comedians are
fact checking cute titles as opposed to
you being literal with your
full frontals samantha b by the way
nobody wants to see that spoiler alert
this show
isn't even definitively all that louder
we haven't stopped returning it's just
unreal to me
that a comedian is wanting to give
someone flack for having university in
the name
because it's an educational series of
video i don't videos i just said i
didn't use my plural because of the
french canadians
do they think baby einstein like what
are they are they furious
is not a member of mensah now it's
something else that's really important
here you know how they always accuse the
right of uh
secret dog whistles like racist dog
whistles remember socialists would say i
think the socialist policy they were
saying that's because you secretly want
to use the n-word so
everything's become a racist or sexist
or homophobic dog whistle
well here's something if we're going to
use that standard of dog whistle that
isn't really a dog it's just a whistle
whistle because everyone can wear it
once exactly samantha bee
goes on to claim that prageru is really
dangerous and she tweeted that out
reiterated it and that's important why
because that's specifically what youtube
policies
prohibit if you look them up right here
youtube dangerous content there we go
you got an overlay
so when you say that a youtube channel
is dangerous
what you are definitively saying here
there's no doubt you're saying please
ban this channel right if you've looked
up the youtube policies a reason for
banning legitimate reasons according to
youtube as if they're a dangerous
channel right and you've accused
the old jewish white-haired guy who just
supports israel free speech and lower
taxes
of effectively being a dangerous nazi by
the way if you're watching this on
youtube right now as opposed to a mug
club where we have
extended and full-length shows that you
don't get every day on youtube please do
hit the notification bell hit all
notifications on youtube because
subscriptions don't mean a whole lot and
uh do consider joining my club okay i
think we have do it
uh oh yeah this next clip this is one of
the most uh
consistent logical fallacies that you
hear a lot right and it's because it's
hard to sort of
check against there's no
anti-conservative bias
on social media oh because you said so
on facebook
right and left leaning pages get nearly
identical rates of reactions comments
and shares with conservative media
outlets such as fox news consistently
getting some of the most engagement okay
it couldn't be less relevant here's all
that proves that conservatives are doing
well
despite shadow banning this is something
that a lot of people outright benny this
is something a lot of people get wrong
happened a lot with uh with uh uh phelps
the the swimmer
yeah it turned out that he ate
mcdonald's almost every day yeah we're
like well you know it worked for phelps
no it didn't work for phelps he probably
would have been
better had he not eaten mcdonald's every
day but if you were graced by
god with a nine foot wingspan hands the
19 shoe that could be put up in a museum
then maybe you too could eat mcdonald's
every day
it doesn't mean that right he ate
mcdonald's therefore he's successful
hey conservatives have the same net
engagements
after all of this therefore they're not
being throttled
no that's not the case maybe their
content is doing so much
better than the leftist content then it
breaks through anyway despite the fact
that we have videos definitive lists
showing
the blacklist of conservative content
you do have to look at the root cause of
this
not at the results and that is important
yeah we have this right here uh this has
happened uh
with us of course pinterest shadow band
um live action
labeled them pornography ben shapiro
commentary was was censored planned
parenthood
undercover videos they were marked as
harmful let me make sure i get this
correct right here
uh there's so many i've forgotten about
these
um facebook right facebook their fact
checker
snopes repeatedly shadow band right well
right-wing satire site babylon b
uh labeling it as fake news it's too
close right now if you go on the crowder
bits channel
the seven plus one way celebrities are
fighting climate change which included
by the way
lizzo turning herself into a raw
milkshare
is fact checked by youtube as being
climate change propaganda
it's not even expressing an opinion
if you search up until very recently
steven crowder changed my mind if you
search that on youtube that was
blacklisted for
a long time with no videos from this
channel showing up in search results
granted
uh months later youtube yep they fixed
it thank you guys we appreciate that but
a lot of searches are still blacklisted
for example right now if you search
steven crowder abortion you're not going
to see any videos
uh from from this channel on the first
page of results and here's what matters
right just because we caught
that right and that's a good thing and
we got it fixed when you type in stephen
credit or changed my mind at one point i
think it was going to a pbs video from
four years ago
20 000 plays please tell me how that
algorithm will make you more profitable
google alphabet inc i'm very curious but
what what does matt what are the chances
if you specifically search stephen
crowder abortion and it doesn't show up
that when you type in abortion debate it
shows up when you type in pro-life
arguments that it shows up
if you type in stephen kreider change my
mind
in the title of the video and it doesn't
show up what happens if you type in
second amendment discussion will it show
up so there's no you can have no hope
to actually be suggested alongside the
likes of samantha bee
if people are specifically searching for
content they've already seen from you
happen to know the title by rote
and they still can't find you but then
at the end of the day because you guys
and we thank you so much you bookmark
this page check in every day because we
have new videos that go up at uh
8 pm eastern every day the plays if you
were to look at them you'd say oh wow
they're doing well
we're doing well in spite of all of that
and that is
by and large because unlike samantha bee
who's propped up by a multi-uh
conglomerate corporation we're not
funded by a foreign caliphate like the
young turks or some
giant corporation like viacom tbs it's
by hand etched mugs and you and your
boxers with a can of
cheetos i see you run the clip
literally no evidence that conservatives
are being silenced
which makes the fact that tech companies
are back into their demands even more
insane
in response to accusations of bias
facebook partnered with right-wing
organizations to fact-check posts and
hire john kyle
a former republican senator to do an
audit of the site zuckerberg also had at
least two
private meetings with donald trump at
the white house but don't worry nothing
shifty happened
people would say the optics weren't good
did he try to lobby you in any way
no i mean i don't think that that's that
i think some of the stuff that people
talk about or think gets discussed in
these discussions are not really how
okay how that works
oh okay um so the premise here is that
there's no there's
literally no evidence of conservatives
being censored which is of course false
just right
uh facebook blacklist youtube blacklist
you can find these things and you can
type them in our channel
but then samantha b says that big tech
is bowing to the demands of
conservatives
just by having one conservative a
republican at the table
samantha b this proves that you don't
believe your own premise because you
think that even
a single conservative being involved
with big tech is
some sort of capitulation yeah but again
by we can make an inference there that
you believe big tech
is by and large a hundred percent left
leaning
and that it should be 100 left you may
believe it's 99
if there's one conservative it's a
problem and you want it to be what
100 what's the number so far again
youtube google facebook they've employed
they mentioned one conservative
organization they're gonna talk about
fact checking yeah yeah they also have
uh southern poverty law center far-left
organizations southern property law
center
adl snopes buzzfeed
salon they can't even fact-check
themselves
too busy promoting pedophiles they were
so i just want to be really clear here
if we want to compare it go tit-for-tat
then please show me the counterbalance
to all these leftist sources
and apparently zuckerberg meeting it's
it's bowing to conservatives demands i
i don't understand this it's just it's
making the field
slightly less uneven keep in mind too
something else youtube partners with vox
they're producing a show with vox they
promote them
on on was it the youtube learning
channel i don't even know what that is
but it's a thing and then uh they just
recently uh invested in the young turks
journalism project oh my gosh
you know we now know what it would take
to please samantha b i think that's
that's that's the silver lining from
this segment think about it
what samantha b wants is for us to ban
the only right-wing
educational channels that are available
uh this is a channel by the way it's not
enough that they already have their
content
marked as um age restricted and of
course that they are
demonetized so this is one thing prager
are using a lawsuit right now because
they're videos that have no profanity
that really don't have
all that controversial content no age
restricted demonetized well content like
samantha b i don't know if they're
entirely monetized but i see ads running
on them all the time so it seems to me
like we have a world with samantha b
where she says prageru
is dangerous which is not a dog whistle
it's simply very basic speak
for please remove this channel uh they
want them
what is the ideal world does anyone else
know i can't i mean no right-wing voices
at all
it seems no center voices at all right
now the only scenario in which samantha
b
is happy is if every single
right-leaning
channel is removed because here's the
thing we've talked about this before
when when people like
like alex jones so i know him isn't
necessarily conservative
or people who are more controversial
figures are removed if
someone wants prageru removed
they effectively want all voices of
dissenting opinion removed
from the platforms of modern life it's
important to note that by the way this
is how people communicate facebook
twitter
youtube uh basically three companies
you're talking about facebook going to
instagram
this is the town square the open town
square and unfortunately
people like samantha b who go out there
or people who work for other giant
corporations whether it's nbc vox or
abc viacom or disney universal and they
go out there and they act as mouthpieces
where at the same time they're asking
for voices of disagreeing opinions to be
removed
as well as their competition and that's
what you're seeing right now with
samantha b and if there's something that
i have wrong samantha b you'd be more
than welcome
to appear on this show and correct me
correct the record because i do have
some evidence i'd like to go over with
you
and talk about as it relates to
conservative shannon batting
conservative throttling conservative
outright banning
and i can actually just send you some
screenshots of this channel by the way
exactly along with every single news
article that relates to the vox
apocalypse here's the thing
i think that you samantha b are uh
grossly overrated i don't want to say
grossly overrated i think you're
immensely untalented unfunny to a point
that
i very rarely use the word offensive but
you are offensively
unfunny and what bothers me even more is
that a no
talent mediocre nothing wants to remove
voices simply because
they disagree with her and they happen
to be more successful than her
all right you let me know what it would
take to request that samantha bee be
removed
i have i think it's great for her to be
out there because i want you by the way
out everyone out there
when you think feminist social justice
warrior leftist okay
i want you to think samantha b so
samantha beef we could get these uploads
to a little more regular than once a
quarter because i know you need more
time off
if you could start doing these every
single day i want you
to be the ambassador i want you to be
emblematic of today's
feminist screeching talentless left i
will go to the ends of the earth to
defend your channel
and your program to make sure that it is
on the air for as long
as humanly possible so long as i don't
have to watch it
hey if you enjoyed this video subscribe
or hit the notification bell
and hit all notifications because uh not
all notifications work now if you just
hit the normal notification bell i think
there's some videos playing in boxes but
of course do consider uh subscribing at
lotterycredit.comclub because there's a
bunch of content that could never make
it
onto youtube and i think the the box is
playing
there's a video playing in a box with